ça va faire 4 ans déjà ce reportage que
ce quils québec le cri du coeur des
femmes autochtone de val-d'or qui
dénonçait toute sorte d'abus non elles
disent avoir été victimes en particulier
de la part de certains policiers de la
sûreté du québec
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis comme
si choqué que la population notamment
parce que klaus qui se croit pas c'est
ce qu'on dit bouleversé la ministre de
la sécurité publique de l'époque
mystérieux qu'on file enquête au service
de police de la ville de montréal cette
enquête va durer un an
[Musique]
rv est suffisante pour accuser les
policiers à val d'or l'événement sur
sept produits c'est que nous n'en avons
pas la peur pour le prouver hors de tout
doute raisonnable
l'association des policiers provinciaux
du québec écrit ne pas être surpris de
cette décision et ajoute que la montagne
venait d'accoucher d'une souris
du côté des femmes autochtones la
consternation se lit sur tous les
visages
nous sommes donc trahie et humiliée et
notre carte bleue et brisé en mille
morceaux
le gouvernement du québec a le devoir
légal et moral d'instituer sans autre
délai une commission denquête public
indépendant devant les pressions de plus
en plus grande
l'ex-premier ministre philippe couillard
annonce en décembre 2016
un an après la crise de val d'or la
tenue de cette enquête publique
juin 2017 c'est au rythme des chants et
des prières que s'ouvre officiellement
les travaux de la commission vient la
confiance banque est maintenant ouvert
la commission offrira et dort name
donnera certainement l'occasion de se
faire entendre aux femmes ainsi qu aux
autres personnes concernées par les
événements dit le val d'or bonjour vu di
fiemme michel présidente de femmes
autochtones du québec sera la première à
prendre la parole
on dépense mort fois femmes dépensent
que des services publics exercer ses
formes de violence toi non édith
cloutier édith cloutier directrice
générale du centre d'amitié autochtone
de val d'or avait été à l'époque
renversé par les témoignages de ces
femmes
ce que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui est
extrêmement grave et inacceptable
c'est vraiment gros si nous sommes
devant cette commission aujourd'hui nous
ne devons d'abord et avant tout au
courage de ces femmes autochtones qui
collectivement ont brisé le silence qui
roule marcil celle qui se fait appeler
coco a travaillé au bar le manoir
fréquenté par les autochtones
nous l'avions rencontré à l'époque jeu
juste pour avoir de tourmag la police
puis un poteau des poumons
il y en a deux trois ou quatre pommes
pourries en gagnant ses taux plein
depuis la diffusion de ce reportage
carole mars il a quitté son métier de
barmaid pour devenir intervenante auprès
de la clientèle autochtone et ça fait
trop zinguerie muzion est sorti
l'émission à 47 3 enfants ou plus cette
pauvre et loquace et lyon ont la vie
facile
la ville de grasse et ce en seulement
jamais ya plein de gens en exergue d'une
journée que c'est un autochtone peuvent
lire devant toi l'heure de midi
aujourd'hui steak normal comme toi gogo
et pas sûr et pas sûr
la qualité de certaines enquêtes
policières a été remise en question et a
suscité auprès des femmes qui ont porté
plainte
beaucoup de frustration deux d'entre
elles à qui nous avions parlé ont tenu à
l'exprimer devant la commission des bras
et niche nous avait raconté dans notre
second reportage son arrestation à la
sortie d'un bar de schefferville
il y avait un temps fait tour le new
york sur une niche [ __ ] de pin ou
médard nine pin ou un vernis marc daoud
a et b brugnens
et baignade aux jeux panarabes dernière
jude hawaï
après ce témoignage des bras et niches a
porté plainte à la police
ils m'ont dit que la plaine n'a pas été
retenu parce qu'il n'y avait pas assez
de preuves vous devez pas c'était moi
j'ai dit vous n'écoutez pas les les
femmes pour les femmes autochtones pays
j'étais fort chez la majorité des
enquêteurs du spvm ont parlé de la
difficulté de mener à terme leur enquête
tu es moins réticents victimes
introuvable malgré l'aide d'intervenants
sociaux s'étaient placés dans les
communautés face du porte à porte pour
aller à laquelle faisaient des personnes
qu'on avait de la difficulté à localiser
l'ensemble des dossiers et que répond la
police dans un instant la version des
hauts gradés de la est ce qu la
commission vient s'est aussi penché sur
le phénomène des cures géographique
plusieurs personnes nous avait raconté
avoir été victime de cette pratique
dangereuse qui consiste à abandonner
quelques à l'extérieur de la ville pour
qu'ils dégrise je tombais up et a pris
part de mr les lâchetés d'abandonner ce
qui en fait est mort et s'il doit partir
c'est à l'hiver
carlina nuit nous avait également révélé
ce qu'elle est une amie avait vécu à la
sortie d'un bar de maniwaki deux
policiers leur aurait offert de les
raccompagner certains des nôtres n'ont
pas survécu à ce genre de voyage ou
quelque chose de grave le rite arrivés
ils ont survécu
mon ami m'a dit de me taire de rester
calme de ne pas les énerver
donc ce soir j'ai réalisé alors qu'il
fallait que je me tienne tranquille
il a fallu huit ans avant que sa peine
soit entendu le dossier a été transféré
à la police de montréal
quand l'enquêteur lui présente des
photos des policiers en fonction ce soir
là le temps avait déjà fait son oeuvre
et au hasard il faisait noir
je me souviens plus trop bien
entre 2007 et 2016
patrick parent du spvm est venu préciser
les conclusions de son enquête
ces mecs là l'addition n'y a pas eu
d'éclats sur une portée mais j'avais
toujours en tête cette question la
police qui enquête sur la police
jusqu'où est elle prête à fouetter
j'envie caire a été agent de liaison
top-ten à la sûreté du québec et
directeur du service de police de lac
simon
les cures géographique il en avait déjà
entendu parler est ce que ça existe à la
sûreté du québec chez des propos des
gens ne sortaient que j'ai entendu un
témoin très attendu à la commission
vient le grand patron de la sûreté du
québec au moment des événements de val
d'or martin prud'homme
est ce que c'est la première fois que
vous entendez parler de ces termes la
structure géographique parce que c'est
un phénomène connu cha la sûreté du
québec
je me surprends pas entendu parler ça a
été lorsque on ne la période d un kite
le on m'a dit que d'un travail et les
abus de pouvoir le y avait eu ce type 2
il y aurait pu avoir eu cette idée
comportement
j'envie caire a dit aussi devant la
commission qu'en 2013 soit deux ans
avant la crise de val d'or il avait
formé là est ce qu que des policiers
auraient commis des gestes de nature
sexuelle à l'endroit de femmes
autochtones sont supérieurs étaient déjà
au courant
à ma grande surprise je le vends encore
et il me dit est ce que ça peut aller
[Musique]
celui-ci est un signal d'alarmé je
montre guinet de monsieur vicaire qui
venait d'ailleurs la communauté de lac
simon
selon son témoignage ne s'est pas rendu
aux autorités
la sûreté du québec on n'a pas retrouvé
de trace écrite de sa valeur un autre
fait marquant de la commission le port
très controversé du bracelet rouge par
des policiers de la sq eu en guise de
solidarité envers leurs huit collègues
suspendu du poste 144 à val d'or ce sont
un symbole de répression cette
l'intimidation peu et m
martin prud'homme a tenu à rétablir les
faits ce bracelet ne visait pas les
autochtones je suis très vite somme vise
jose a dit qu'une main personnellement
parce que c'est le magicien données d
avoir relevé les policiers ne retirons
ce bracelet que lorsque leurs huit
collègues et la sûreté du québec en
viendront à une entente
ils seront dédommagés puis bien entendu
ce qu'ont vécu des jours pour apprendre
le travail toute la commission puis
votre rapport final contre les premiers
à faire le suivre sur ce que ce qui
était démontré ici ce qu'on faisait de
bien ce qu'on doit faisait de moins bien
mais ce qu'on faisait vraiment de ten de
très négatif
pourquoi juste
en tout les audiences de la commission
vient ont duré trente huit semaines une
leçon d'histoire magistral sur les
relations troubles entre les services
publics et les autochtones du québec
on va savoir très bien tout ce que la
commission vient va retenir de tous ces
témoignages parce que le rapport final
sera déposé à la fin septembre
c'est tout pour ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]